welcome back to my favorite movies the
new segment I started where I can tell
you guys about some of my favorite
movies it's very self-explanatory
as you may continue to watch these
you'll notice that no not all my
favorite movies are necessarily
considered the big classics of our
generation
I do enjoy quite a bit of different
types of films classics included like
pulp fiction or Shawshank Redemption
which oddly both came out in 1994
connections that's how my brain works
that just it just spouts things I
apologize but another one of my favorite
films is in fact the 1987 film directed
by John McTiernan starring Arnold
Schwarzenegger predator now I got a few
questions on my last video my overlooked
review for Cowboy Bebop the movie a lot
of people were wondering what some of
the stuff behind me was in my new
background that is in fact an action
figure of Dutch from predator standing
right next to John McClane also a really
cool guy and they are both from films
directed by John McTiernan the man
understood action back in the 80s and
early 90s he did a lot of really good
films and predator was the film he made
directly before die hard and this film
honestly is one of the coolest action
movies I've ever seen
and a meat Rescue Squad you're bleeding
man ain't got time that lead is being
led by the ultimate warrior we need the
best that's why you're here the plot is
really very simple to sum up Arnold
Schwarzenegger and his team of extremely
awesome manly men are sentient to the
Central American jungle looking for
hostages there they encounter a creature
who can cloak himself who can hide
within the trees and this creature is
picking each one of them off for sport
and it becomes a battle to the death
between Swartz Nagar and the predator
now this movie could have come off so
cheesy like some crappy b-movie but it
didn't thanks to John McTiernan terrific
direction he really understands how to
use his location and you can feel it in
every single shot because McTiernan did
such a good job to make sure you could
see foliage or trees or swamp
stuff or you know waterfalls or rivers
you could always see this like in every
shot it was like you felt so
claustrophobic in that jungle with those
guys Alan Silvestri's score really adds
something really cool to this movie - it
has that great 80s testosterone to it
and there are times in this movie that
you really just you feel the adrenaline
pumping in you because of mctierney's
direction combined with actually one of
the better sports negra performances out
there and Silvestri's score and it
really just pumps you up the way this
movie goes on and on and on you feel the
suspense from each scene like I
literally can watch this movie over and
over again because each scene feels like
okay this scene ends and it was awesome
and then it branches right into the next
one perfectly the movie has a terrific
pace never once is there a boring moment
in this film from start to finish you
are constantly on the edge of your seat
throughout predator but no let's go this
is booked through something else
awaiting foolish
they're up against the ultimate enemy
holy mother cos nothing like it has ever
been on earth before she says the jungle
just came alive and took it ah we cannot
see
no blood no bodies we nothing it's
really easy to think of predator and go
it's predator you know it's that sports
and nigger movie from the 80s they made
a ton of crappy sequels and it's just
predator no I actually think this is on
the same level if not just slightly
above the original alien and its sequel
aliens
I think predator is truly a classic
science fiction film no it is not your
typical sci-fi movie it is more of an
action film than it is sci-fi but the
combination of the two in this movie
along with Schwarzenegger is terrific
charisma and on-screen appeal that just
made predator be something better than
it really should have been there are so
many great lines in this movie of course
you have the famous get to the chopper
line which everyone loves to quote over
and over again but directly after that
happens there's this great moment in the
film that to me really signifies where
Predator kicks itself into high gear
Swartz nigga rolls over in the grass and
he just crawls for a while and alan
silvestri score just booms really loudly
and it to me that scene always signified
okay it's just sports nigger in the
creature now it is on because it seems
so intense with that music and the way
the movie progressed after that there
literally is like one to two more
sentences of dialogue in the film the
last half-hour the movie has like no
dialogue and you're completely riveted
and that is a testament to John
McTiernan direction the score the
production design as Swartz Nager
himself who actually gives a really good
performance in this movie I know he's
actually really legitimately great in
this movie predator is a movie that
could have been really silly but it was
not it was a great action film with
adrenaline pumping scenes good
performances great use of location and
really good direction and one of my
favorite scores from the 80s actually
one of my favorite scores of all time if
you haven't seen predator please check
it out even if action movies on your
thing don't be dissuaded by the fact
that it has sports and they grow on the
cover holding a gun and it looks no
stereotypical it's not predator is
awesome and it's one of my all-time
favorite films I'm going to give
predator an A+
if you guys are continuing to enjoy
these reviews like you did my Scott
Pilgrim review I'll continue to do more
of my favorite movie reviews in the
future for you guys and as always if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes